How can I get an assessment on supplements I need for detoxification? I have DNA,
enzymatic health issues, and have been currently using some of your products.
PUD will assist, pro-SD, canelae, CVS, VHMT assist,
so for those that don't understand, those are supplements that are specific for a different gene
pathway, so if people have genetic defects in their PUD 1 pathways, which is a
liver phase 1, phase 2 pathway assist, that's how you get rid of toxins, chemicals, pesticides,
things like that. If you, if a person has done a genetic workup and they have a lot of defects in
their PUD 1 pathway, that might be a product that we would, that product was specifically formulated
to help with the PUD 1 pathway, so if they have defects, a lot of defects in the PUD 1 pathway,
we might recommend, or practitioner might recommend that product called PUD 1 assist.
Same thing, if you have defects in your superoxide disutase canelae pathways,
they may recommend SOD canelae, or a practitioner may just recommend SOD canelae,
if they know they're exposed to a lot of oxidants, because SOD canelae are antioxidants,
and the same with the CVS, VHMT, their CVS is a specific gene in the glutathione pathway,
your, your VHMT as another gene family, if you have defects on those genes, then those products
might be recommended. Continuing with the question to help get rid of toxins, but looking
beyond this, because I did a feel well, GI, neural, circulation, etc., I would like a personalized
recommendation protocol to address my personal needs. Yes, so if you want a personalized recommendation
from us, you will want to start with what's called a case review, so if you go to our website
cuttersclinic.com, you'll see a tab that says start here or begin here, you can click on that,
and cuttersclinic.com is mainly all about cancer, because that's our primary patient members
that we see these days, but have for years, but we also have a sister site called My Hope for
Lime, similar, but it talks about Lyme disease, it talks about autoimmune disease, it talks about
general functional medicine, it doesn't make a difference which site you go to. You can self-schedule,
on either one of those sites, at a fact, I think that my hope for Lyme sites pushes you back to the
cuttersclinic site to schedule. No, but I think that's the page that you go to the schedule. No,
certainly, you could just call the clinic and talk to the read or whoever answers the phone
and ask them about options, but you'd start with a case review, if you want help from us, I mean,
so if you want My Hope, start with a case review, that's a 30-minute consultation with me,
we'll do a full consultation, and we'll go over your symptoms that may make recommendations for
different labs, and we want to look at the labs that you've had done so far. And you talk about,
okay, I'm supporting these genetic pathways, but I still don't feel well. You're missing something.
So is it something as simple as a food issue? Is it something as simple as dealing with neuroinflammation?
Also on our website, there's thousands plus different blog posts with different videos that go over
a lot of those things. So if you're having specific neurological symptoms, you can search for those
on our blog search, on our website search, and you may find it's more information that will help you,
but you'd start, you want to work with us, you'd want to start with a case review, you want to work
with somebody else, I would hope that they would recommend labs that would get to the bottom of it,
because you always want to get to the bottom of what is the cause of your issue, and most of the
other stuff, it's genetic. It's something functional, it's going to help.